>> From the library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Hello
everyone and welcome to our panel
on Artists' Rights and
the Digital Marketplace.
The goal of our panel tonight
is to facilitate a conversation
about artists' rights and about some
of the issues surrounding
getting paid for our work
in the digital marketplace.
We've assembled an excellent
panel of music professionals
who will share their different
perspectives on the issues.
And after hearing from them, we will
look forward to hearing from you
about your questions and concerns.
So, we have some heavy
hitters with us tonight.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about who's here on our panel.
Maria Schneider who is doing her
week long-jazz residency here at LC,
is a world renown composer
and leader
of the Maria Schneider Orchestra.
She has received five Grammy
awards for her recordings,
the most recent being, the most
recent two being Best Arrangement
instruments and vocals for her
collaboration with the late,
great David Bowie, on the single
called Sue, or In a Season of Crime.
And Best Large Jazz Ensemble album
for her latest work,
the Thompson Fields.
In addition to being
an accomplished artist,
Maria's a very successful
entrepreneur whose 2004 album,
Concert in the Garden, became
historic as the first recording
to win a Grammy with
internet-only sales.
And that album also pioneered
the crowd funding boom
as the first album ever released
on the Artist Share platform.
Maria's also a passionate voice
for music advocacy as you're going
to hear tonight, having
testified before Congress
about digital rights, appeared
on CNN, and being quoted
in numerous publications
for her views
on digital rights and music piracy.
Most recently, she and
concerned colleagues in New York,
have launched a wide
spread campaign on behalf
of music makers, musicanswers.org.
And you're going to be hearing more
about musicanswers.org very soon.
To my right, John Simson here
is Executive in Residence
at the Kogod School of Business
at American University here
in Washington, D.C. He started
out in the music biz in 1971
as a recording artist
and songwriter.
Since then, John's career has
included stints as a manager,
handling the career of five-time
Grammy, Mary Chapin Carpenter,
special advisor to Harry Belafonte
for music and TV projects,
and a 30 year career,
a 30 year career
as an entertainment lawyer
advising clients on copyright
and business issues
in film, television,
music and the visual arts.
John was at the forefront of the
battle for the artist's right
to be paid in the digital era.
From 2001 to 2010 he served as
the founding executive director
of SoundExchange, an organization he
helped launch to collect royalties
from internet and satellite
radio services on behalf
of recording artists
and record labels.
SoundExchange has now distributed
over $2 billion dollars to artists
and labels since it began.
>> John Simson: If I'd
only had stock options.
>> Jennifer Cutting: John is
currently president of the Music
and Entertainment Industry Educators
Association and he also serves
on our National Recording
Preservation Board here
at the Library of Congress.
So, we see him a lot.
Spree Wilson in the middle there,
is a singer songwriter who was born
in Nashville, Tennessee, and
attended Clark University
in Atlanta, Georgia, where he met
one of his mentors, Dallas Austin.
Dallas was impressed by
Spree's guitar skills
and offered him an internship
at his famous studio, D.A.R.P.,
as well as offering him
a recording contract.
Spree turned down the recording
contract, sold his car,
and bought a one-way ticket
to New York City arriving
with just a suitcase and a guitar.
Being in the Big Apple, led to
his meeting with his other mentor,
rapper producer Q-Tip, who helped
land Spree a major label deal
with Jive Records and
ultimately a publishing deal
with Universal Music Group.
And since then, Spree has co-written
Afrojack's single, The Spark,
which I looked at today and realized
that you've got almost 35
million views for the Spark.
Which has been A listed
on BBC's Radio 1.
In addition, he's co-written
Sin City
on Good Music Compilation album,
Cruel Summer with Teyana Taylor.
The album went number 1 on the
U.S. top R&B Hip-Hop Albums,
U.S. Top Rap Albums, and
number 2 on U.S. Billboard 200.
In addition to Q-Tip,
Spree has collaborated
with other note-worthy producers
such as Novel, No ID, Jim Jonsin,
Infamous, Malay, Robin Hannibal,
Frequency, and Mark Maxwell.
Please welcome our
panelists tonight.
[ Applause ]
Even though we're living
in a time when brick
and mortar record stores have all
but disappeared, the good news is
in the digital realm, it's never
been easier to share our music.
But the bad news is also, it's never
And millions are helping themselves
to it and expecting it for free.
So we need to have strategies
to protect our music
and to get paid for it.
So, my first question
to our panelists is,
and I'm going to address
this to Spree first.
As we trend, we've transitioned from
a purchase model where people paid
to buy downloads and physical
CDs, we've transitioned
to an access model where consumers
can stream almost anything they want
on demand.
What, if anything, about that is
working, and what is not working?
And what's the financial reality
that you're living
with, as an artist?
>> Spree Wilson: Well, I think
you have to, I think you have
to first ask yourself, like what
is it that you're looking for,
or are hoping for as
an artist, you know.
I mean, the general, most
basic thing that you want
as a creative is to be heard.
You want to be seen,
you want your art,
to at least mean something
to one person.
So, these streaming companies,
like Spotify and Apple Music,
and things like You tube,
they help you get your music
and your art out there.
They give you to access to people
in a bigger abundance of, you know,
you can cast a wider net rather
than 24 or 23 years ago, like,
you have to perform
in a club and hope
that like more than
5 people show up.
So, you know.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Right.
>> Spree Wilson: So, so yeah, that's
the positive aspect, you know.
The downside is that there's
no transparency, right.
Like, I put my music on Spotify,
there's music on Youtube,
it racks up a total of like, I
don't know, 30 million views.
>> Jennifer Cutting: 35.
>> Spree Wilson: 35 million views.
I have a song that's 45
million on Spotify right now.
But I have no idea what that equals,
because Spotify in a sense they get
to make up their own numbers, right?
They get to say, well, we're
going to pay you, point, point,
point zero four for your song.
Now where do you get
that number though?
Like how can you equate, how can
you, like, what is the equation
that you put this price
tag on this piece of art?
And then they've said, well, on top
of that, you know, if your song is
through a major label,
or you've collaborated
with somebody who's signed to
a major publishing company,
what we're going to do is we're
going to have this lump sum
of money and we're pay them.
Now, we're not going to tell
you how much we're paying them,
just know that we're paying them
70% of whatever we're making,
whatever that number is, right?
So it gives this pile
of money to the labels.
And the label says, well we're
doling out the money as best we can.
How much money is it, though?
You just don't know.
And so it's still just this thing
of non-transparency that gets passed
around and all this red tape you
have to go through, like, how much,
how much does 45 million streams
on Spotify equal moneywise?
>> Jennifer Cutting: How
much does it translate into?
>> Spree Wilson: Yeah,
and you just never know.
Like you just never know if you're
getting the right amount of money.
I mean for example, like just for
my own personal business out there,
the song she's referring
to, The Spark,
and on Spotify it has
45 million streams,
it's Afrojack second highest
streamed song on Spotify.
Every quarter probably it's
streamed at least a million times,
which a quarter is 3 months.
When I get a royalty statement,
they pay in 4 quarters.
So every 3 months, I
get a royalty statement.
The highest I've ever
been paid on Spotify
for a million streams, is $60.
If that give you any idea of what,
of what a high-stream
song will pay you.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And, John?
>> John Simson: Now to be
clear that's you being paid
as a songwriter, not as the artist.
The artist actually gets
paid a little bit more.
>> Spree Wilson: A
little bit more, but.
>> John Simson: Yeah,
it's a little bit better.
>> Spree Wilson: But, but--
>> Maria Schneider: So you
can eat a nice restaurant,
as opposed to taking
your friend to a diner.
>> John Simson: I'll go through some
of those numbers in a little bit.
Because I've spent my life since
running SoundExchange looking
at those numbers and
they're pretty pitiful.
We throw around terms like
ARPU, average revenue per user.
You know, or annual revenue per
user, how much does each user
of a service like Spotify generate?
And obviously the problem is there
are some people paying $9.99 a
month, if you're paying $10 a month
for Spotify, that's $120 a year
that you're paying for music.
That's not bad.
If, you know, if 60% of that is
being transferred over to the label
and the artist to share, $72
you can sit there and 10%,
typically it's 10.5%,
gets transferred
to the song writer
and the publisher.
So, they're going to make $12.60
if you're the song
writer and publisher.
But remember, the more people
stream, the lower your rate gets.
Because they more they have to pay
out for the $10 a month
that you're paying.
So they love people who
subscribe and then don't use it.
You know, it's kind of like
breakage, but most people use a lot.
I can tell you in the first
5 years of SoundExchange,
we logged in 7 billion performances.
And again, it's before Pandora,
before some of the major
streaming services existed.
2001 to 2006, 7 billion
performances.
>> Maria Schneider: From multiple
locations on the internet.
So everybody--
>> John Simson: These are all
streaming music, so they'd have
to be non-interactive, streaming
like college radio stations,
AOL had a streaming service.
CBS, all the broadcasters
who stream on line.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Can
you explain the difference
between interactive
and non-interactive?
>> John Simson: Sure.
A non-interactive service
is like Pandora,
where you can't pick the song
you want when you want it.
You can go to Pandora and say,
I want to hear Taylor Swift.
And they'll play you a Taylor Swift
song and then they'll play you a lot
of other songs that they
think you'll want to hear.
It's more like a radio station.
You can't specifically say, in
fact the worse thing to do is say,
I want to hear this
song by Taylor Swift,
because then they can't
play you that song.
They're not allowed to play you
the song that you asked for,
because they get a compulsory
license from the government.
So they can play anything they want.
Taylor Swift cannot take
her music off Pandora.
She can take it off Spotify, she can
take it off any interactive services
because in the interactive world
where you can demand the song
you want, when you want it,
artists have the right to say no.
It's usually their label
that has the right to say no.
But there is some control there,
which is why you see an artist
like Drake say, I'm going to
give an exclusive to Apple Music.
Or you see an artist like Kanye say,
I'm giving an exclusive
to Tidal Music.
So artists can have those kinds
of exclusive relationships
in the on demand world.
In the Pandora world, or when
broadcasters stream online,
called simulcasting,
so I Heart Radio,
where you hear Clear Channel
stations streamed online,
or Bonneville or CBS, any of
the big radio conglomerates.
When they stream online, they have
a compulsory license given them
by the government, and basically
what it says is you can stream
whatever you want,
anything publically released
in the U.S. is fair game.
All you have to do is
pay the royalty rate set
by the copyright royalty
board that's located here
in the Library of Congress.
And you have the data
to SoundExchange
of what you played, so
they know who to pay.
So, you know, so, non-interactive
is very easy,
it's kind of a plug and play.
You know, you basically
start streaming tomorrow
and no one can sue you.
You have to get about
four licenses to do that.
And they're licenses that
people have to give you.
So, it's a very easy situation.
Spotify and on-demand
services, much more difficult.
So for example, when Spotify
needs to stream music,
they have to negotiate a
license with every single owner
of the master recordings.
Whoever owns those recordings,
typically record labels,
which is why the major
labels in order
to let Spotify exist took
20% equity in Spotify.
So the major record labels
are investors in Spotify,
or they have equity, they
are waiting for the IPO.
>> Spree Wilson: And now SoundCloud.
>> John Simson: Yeah, this is the
case with pretty much any service
that needs those massive catalogs
of recordings that are owned
by Universal, Warner, and Sony.
That they can demand equity to allow
these services to stream on demand.
Think of Spotify, and Apple,
and Tidal and these services
that serve you up records
when you ask for them.
They're the replacement
for record stores, right?
Because you're getting to
hear exactly what you want,
when you want to hear it.
Obviously, there are some holdbacks.
Adele didn't put her
record on Spotify, or,
you know, on streaming services.
And there's a big battle going
on too between paid services.
You don't get Apple
unless you pay for it.
You don't get Tidal
You might have a free trial
for a very limited period
of time, but you have to pay.
Spotify has the free tier,
which is the overwhelming tier,
600 million unique users.
Versus the paid tier,
where there are
about 30 million worldwide users.
So you can see, 20 to 1.
Pandora, the same way.
They have both ad supported
service, most of their users are
on the ad supported free service,
where they don't pay anything.
Kind of like the old radio model,
you listen to ads and you get music.
But, it's interesting, you
pay $4.00 a month to get rid
of the ads, very few people do.
They're willing to take
the 2 minutes of ads.
I kept yelling at Pandora,
you need 10 minutes of ads.
Because that way musicians
actually can make a living,
more people will buy the ad
free because they don't want
to listen to 10 minutes of ads.
And it's very interesting,
the free service
of Pandora generates last
year about $1 billion dollars.
Last year $1.1 billion.
81 million users, if
you do the math,
they earned about $13
-$14 per person, per year.
Right? Over the air radio, the
Clear Channels of the world
that you listen to when
you're in your car,
with their 10 minutes
of advertising.
They earn $71 per person, per year.
I already mentioned, Spotify,
if you're paying for it,
$120 per person, per year.
Satellite radio at $15.
Sirus XM $150 to $160
per person, per year.
So, you can see that
subscription isn't a bad thing
if people are actually paying.
It can generate a liveable
wage, if people are paying.
If people are not paying,
it's really, really difficult.
And YouTube is the worse.
Because YouTube with over a billion
users, generated less than 4%
of the industry's revenue
last year in royalties.
So that's the real problem.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Speaking of a living wage,
what would Spree's career look like
in the old days of record stores?
I mean, compared to the $60
he makes from massive numbers
of people streaming his music.
What would his career
look like in the old days?
>> John Simson: Well I think--
>> Jennifer Cutting: With just as
many people listening to his music.
>> John Simson: The hard part is
translating listens into sales.
But for example, I think the
way to look at it would be,
if he had 45 million
listens on the radio,
how much would ASCAP or BMI pay him?
Right? And you know, again, the
rates online have been horribly low.
Partially because, because of
radio, ASCAP and BMI were locked
into very low rates
with traditional media.
And so when they went online, they
continued to get very low rates,
kind of mirroring what
they were getting at radio.
And online music is not
like, really like radio.
It's much more personalized.
It's a much, you know, more
interesting listening experience
and so it's capturing more
and more listening hours,
and yet not paying
out what it should.
And by contrast, SoundExchange
didn't, we didn't have a radio rite
in the United States
for recording artists.
That's another problem we
can talk about another time.
The hundreds of millions of
dollars that U.S. artists lose
because radio stations don't
have to pay them anything.
But because we didn't have a 3%, 4%
legacy radio rate, we're getting 50%
of Pandora revenue, whereas song
writers are getting 4 or 5%.
So the artists are getting 10
times as much as song writers,
and that's not fair, frankly.
Song writers should
be getting far more.
You know, these services
need to monetize better.
>> Jennifer Cutting: If you
don't want it on YouTube,
you can ask them to take it down.
There's a way to.
It's tortuous.
>> Spree Wilson: It's a
very, like, she can tell you.
>> Jennifer Cutting: I'd like
to turn it over to Maria,
to talk about the take downs.
>> Maria Schneider: Well, there's
so many things to talk about here.
It's incredible.
One thing just before I go into
that, that I'd like to talk
about because to me, one of the
most eroded royalties and rites
that I feel is very
frustrating and has been
around since the piano roll, and
that's the mechanical royalty.
When something is fixed onto a
record, onto a CD, onto a download,
onto a device where you can play it,
there is a statutory rate
approximately 9 cents a song,
that was always figured into
the cost of making a record.
Right? And now, that note, we know,
Spree and I were just talking today,
about the fact that you can
get, there are all sorts of apps
out there now, that you can
rip an MP3 off of any video.
You know, in a matter of seconds.
And have it.
And if you can listen it again
on demand again and again,
we know that this is a
replacement for buying that music.
We know that.
Because people are not
buying music as much anymore.
So if I think about
your 45 million plays,
and what I believe should
be happening, because to me,
what really angers me
about the whole business is
that people are not
looking at the music.
Maybe because it's not
fixed in form as an asset.
I mean, it used to be in
Tower Records, they would put,
Marshall Gilkes, in my band, he was
just pointing out, remember in Tower
when they put that plastic thing
around so you couldn't steal the CD.
Right? Wrapped a thing of
plastic around this record,
that had to be taken off
when you purchased it.
So when it was in physical form,
somehow we all looked
it at that way.
Now that it's in digital form,
we aren't looking at it that way.
And so, people aren't looking at,
at something that costs
money, is of value.
When I made my record The Thompson
Fields, it was $200,000 to make
that record, pay the
players, the engineers,
the everything, the hours of mixing.
A year of my time and I did not
include myself in that budget.
Then, I haven't included
the years writing
that music, preparing that music.
This is a $400,000 investment, okay?
So, when my music is played,
I, somewhere, or is distributed
in some kind of way, I want
to set my own price point
because I know the cost of that.
And if my music, I would
never put my music on Spotify.
You could sooner roll
me over in, in whatever.
But, say my music was
on something like that,
you can bet I wouldn't want somebody
basing the mechanical royalty
on a percentage of what that
company tells me their profits are.
So, that's how they're figuring
out these mechanical royalties.
It's a, it's a percentage of
their net profit and the value
of the big data company is a
very difficult thing to value.
Because their value is
something that grows and grows.
We know, what's the value of Google?
Google is all that data,
it's all that power,
it's not just the advertising,
it's the data analytics.
It's the capability that they
know, you know, that this person
who listens to this music,
all the things that crawl
around your devices that
know everything that you do.
The data lords are taking, that's
the name of the piece I've written
for the Library of Congress, Data
Lords, are taking, appropriately.
Are just you know, taking
all this information
and becoming hugely powerful.
So, to me, each unique listen, if
somebody listens to more than a half
of your song, they can listen
a thousand times, I don't care.
But that first time they
listen a full time through,
or let's say two times,
let's be generous
to the new internet generation.
I believe that, that person
automatically should have to pay
that 9 cents mechanical to you.
And that's, imagine
how huge that would be.
I don't know how many unique,
do you know how many unique
users, listeners you have?
>> Spree Wilson: That's
something to look into.
>> Maria Schneider: Well, okay.
So let's just say it's 4.5 million.
So you know, if it's 4.5 million
and it's 9 cents, what is that?
>> John Simson: It's a
little under $450,000.
>> Maria Scheider: So it's $450,000,
there's a half million
dollars almost,
in his pocket for his mechanicals.
And you know what?
With the kind of use you have,
you should be buying an apartment.
I'm sorry.
You know, really?
So, anyway, the mechanical
royalty erosion is the first thing
that has just, you
know, made me crazy.
If you look at these big data
companies and what they're doing,
and right now the Office of
Copyrights is doing a study
on safe harbor provisions.
And these companies
like YouTube and Google,
and all the internet companies.
So in 1998 they created
something called the DMCA,
which is the Digital
Millennium Copyright Act.
It was designed to protect these
ISP's, this is before Napster,
before all these things, these
ISP's that were basically pipelines
for information coming
through, you know.
And they didn't really know AOL,
you know, Verizon, I don't know,
they didn't really know exactly what
was coming through their pipeline.
So they said, we don't
want to be liable.
We can't be liable when we
don't even know what's coming
through the pipes.
So they said okay, so
you get Safe Harbor.
But then they created
this, take down.
I don't know when the
takedown was created.
>> John Simson: It was, it's
part of the negotiation in 512.
>> Maria Schneider: Part of
the negotiation, is that people
who were being infringed, if
their work was being infringed,
they could have, file a takedown.
So these companies
had to have some place
where that person had the
capability to go up and you know,
and file this takedown notice.
The problem is now with
these new companies.
Look at YouTube.
This is a modern day
wholesale publishing company.
They are, and they are inducing,
you know, there was a case
between Viacom and YouTube.
Because Viacom said,
you know, they're,
they're letting our music come up.
They shouldn't be getting Safe
Harbor and it went to court.
They lost but then Viacom
appealed and the judge looked at it
and said there are some
interesting facts here.
I think we're going to send this
down to the trial court again
and take a look at this.
And there were employees at YouTube
that indicated that they had,
you know, instigated and
induced this infringement
which they are not allowed to do.
And that's what the court
was trying to decide.
Is, are these companies aiding
and abetting this infringement?
The answer is without question, yes.
All you have to do is go to
YouTube and upload something.
You upload in 2 seconds
flat, no questions asked.
Nobody says, do you own this?
Or, so, I can show them in a little
while, I brought up some kind
of interesting things on YouTube.
For instance, you can cue in, or
search no infringement intended.
Let's see what happens here,
if we do that, what comes up.
Okay. Let me just see if I can
find it easily and quickly.
No infringement intended.
>> On the e.
>> Maria Schneider:
On the e, thank you.
There we go.
You know what, can
you do this for me?
Because you're.
No copyright infringement intended.
659,000 people have uploaded stuff
and it says no copyright
infringement intended.
I just really want to
share this band, you know.
And then these things get
like millions of views.
So YouTube, I mean, they
know this stuff is there.
And so if you want to take it down
immediately, so there's no warning
that says when you put
it up, exclamation point.
If you don't own this music,
or you didn't write the music,
or you haven't gotten permission,
you could be in a lot of trouble.
But if you want to take your music
down, there's a big yellow thing
with an exclamation point,
under penalty of perjury,
you better not be, you
know, taking down something
that isn't yours otherwise you
could be in a lot of trouble
and there's question after question.
It's honest to God, it's incredible.
It's, and clearly they want people
to be able to put this stuff up.
There are people, this week,
I, there was a situation
where I was digging around,
it's fun to dig around YouTube
to see just how egregious
some of this stuff is.
So I happened to see
a site with just tons
of independent jazz musicians.
I'm a jazz musician, so
I know all these people.
So a guy might be on, you know,
he had several albums uploaded
on some young guy's YouTube
channel, hundreds of records.
So, I spoke to Clarence, Clarence
said oh my God, that's crazy.
So the guy ended up,
he contacted this guy,
he ended up taking
his whole site down,
because I think he got freaked
out, his whole YouTube channel.
And, I found the teacher of this
person, because he was a young guy,
and I said I want to talk to him,
and find out some things from him.
And I said, I promise I won't use
your name, I won't tell anybody
about you, I just want
to find out some facts
because there were ads on all these.
They were all full albums, full
albums, they all had a string of ads
on them, and he had I think
it was 3.5 million views.
Okay? So if you look on YouTube what
they charge for an ad, between 10
and 30 cents, so imagine what
they're bringing, you know, in.
So, let's, let's say it's only
one ad on each one for 10 cents,
3.5 million, that's, how much?
>> John Simson: Typically,
YouTube's been paying
out about $2,000 per million views.
And I think, some of the major
companies may get a little bit
higher rate, but YouTube--
>> Maria Schneider:
Wait, 2 million what?
>> John Simson: $2,000
per million views.
So it's incredibly low.
>> Maria Schneider:
It's incredibly--
>> John Simson: But in other words--
>> Maria Schneider:
What are they taking?
>> John Simson: Oh, they won't
tell you how much they're making.
>> Maria Schneider: Well, what
was interesting with this kid,
I promise I won't tell anybody,
what are you making on those ads?
He said, I didn't make anything.
YouTube generated those
ads, it came on their own.
He said I don't know
where the money was going.
And he said, I presumed
that because they did that,
and a lot of the stuff was somewhere
else on YouTube, it was okay.
So, you see, this whole
thing is serving YouTube.
It's, it's taking what ours
and taking it away and trying
to make us feel like
it's doing something good
for us, and it is not.
>> Spree Wilson: A lot of the kids,
like the ones she is referring to.
They don't really know that they're
doing anything wrong, you know.
They have no idea what they're
doing, they're uploading music.
And, you know, we talked about
this specific situation, you know,
this kid thinks the ad money
is going to the artist.
You know, meanwhile, her friend
doesn't even know his music is
on YouTube.
He's looking at me like why
is my whole album on YouTube.
And so it's this whole thing,
like, where, it brings me back
to my first question,
where is the money?
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Spree Wilson: Who,
like, who has the money?
>> Maria Schneider: I'll
tell you who has it.
You know, what it is, it's
a redistribution of wealth.
That's what it is.
By big data companies.
So, it's, they use music and this
is my beef with Sony, Universal,
and Warner, and Spotify, too.
It's like a feeding frenzy here,
everybody panicked what to do,
you know, when things
started to go south
with the internet and file sharing.
And so, and I had the perfect
solution and I'm still doing it
through Artist Share, which I'll
explain later, which is basically
about self-ownership and
selling directly to the fan,
and knowing who the fan
is and owning my own data.
But what these companies did is they
realized how do we, on the internet,
how do we get eyeballs
so that can amass data,
so that we can sell advertising.
We give them entertainment, we give
them music, we give them movies.
We give them all these things,
just to attract eyeballs.
And so how do you get more eyeballs?
You make that music free.
And YouTube somehow tried to,
when I testified before Congress,
I was next to one of the general
counsels of YouTube and she had the,
I just couldn't even believe I
heard her talking about a woman who,
you know, had a million plus views,
and it really helped her career,
and it was really wonderful,
and it really worked for her.
As like this is doing us a favor.
I said, that is, I, okay, so
maybe this woman it was a success
for her in some way.
Maybe she was a songwriter
that was actually a performer,
let's not forget that a lot of
songwriters are not performers.
So, I said that's like going into
a poverty stricken neighborhood,
finding one person that wins
the lottery and calling--
>> Spree Wilson: Making
them the exception.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah, this is
a great sustainable economic model.
Look at this person,
what they've achieved.
You can all hope for this, you know?
I was like oh, please.
So, anyway, so what happened
is Spotify needed music, right?
They want to be this
big data company.
Daniel Ek wants to be
the answer to piracy.
I mean, honestly, you know,
to me, he's the pirate
in sheep's clothing, you know.
So, what did they do
to get all that music,
because they couldn't
really get the library?
They gave the equity to
Sony, Universal and Warner.
And Sony, Universal and Warner did
it, nobody really knew about it.
It was money that now, one of
them, I think it was Warner,
said somehow you know,
since everybody's been really
making a hullabaloo about this,
like we'll distribute it.
How do you distribute it?
Somebody dies, you're going to go
back and find the estate, I mean.
This is, someday when
they're equity comes through,
it's utterly ridiculous.
And so, these companies, now
that represent these artists
through their contracts, maybe
this is a harsh way to say it,
but I dare, I'm going
to use a harsh analogy.
I feel like a lot of these artists,
it's almost now, these companies,
they're now big data companies.
They're no longer music companies.
They have equity.
They're in the business
of making music free
so that their equity can go up.
And that they can make
money in other ways.
And so these musicians that
are tied to these people,
it's like being chain
ganged to working, you know,
I'm doing my music while they,
so that can sell it for free and,
or give it away for free and
become more valuable by it.
It's completely wrong.
If I had one wish, it would be that
artists could, if there was a way
to say, you have broken our
fiduciary trust, you have, this,
you represented me as an
artist, as a publisher,
at my financial interest, and
you sold me down the river.
I want out.
Because you know, how many
musicians had contracts that foresaw
in them these other ways
of distributing music?
I mean, you can say
that you're a lawyer--
>> John Simson: Oh, I mean
there's been a huge issue
in the music industry
over the last decade
because of the way
music is distributed.
And one of the big cases
actually was brought
by Eminem's production company, FBT
versus Aftermath, Dr. Dre's label.
When songs were being sold on
iTunes for 99 cents, you know,
the record company would say,
oh, we're selling a single,
it's just like the way
we used to sell singles,
and so you get 12% of the dollar.
So here's your 12 cents.
They pay 9.1 cents to the
publisher for the mechanical,
that's 21.1 cents, and they
keep the rest of the money
that iTunes would pay them.
iTunes out of the 99 cents
would keep about a quarter,
so there'd be about another 50 cents
the record company would pocket.
So Eminem's producer said no,
no, you're not selling anymore.
You're licensing Apple the music.
And when you went in to
look at the contracts,
most artists' contracts say,
if you sell it, it's 12%,
but if you license it, we get half.
So all of a sudden the record labels
had to pay half of the money to all
of these legacy artists from the
70's, the Allman Brothers sued.
There was a big Warner settlement,
there was a big Universal
settlement,
there was a big Sony settlement.
So that was great.
That was a great windfall
for all the legacy artists
because their contracts
didn't say anything.
In, starting in 2003, now
that we knew iTunes was the
way we were selling music,
in those contracts going forward,
it says when we sell through iTunes,
it's a sale, it's not a license.
So they've protected
themselves going forward.
I actually think, Maria, that
the label's taking equity.
I mean, there's definitely
a cynical view.
And I don't know that they
ever planned to share it
with the artists, the fact that
they were using these vast catalogs
of music to get the equity share.
And now they've had to come
forward and say, oh well,
we'll share this with, you know--
>> Maria Schneider: One of them has.
>> John Simson: If there's ever an
IPO, no all three I think, have.
They've all come forward.
But I actually think it was the
record companies finally having
that ah-ha moment, so
they had the opportunity
to own MTV and they didn't.
They had the opportunity
to own Soundscan,
which creates data
about sales, and didn't.
You think about the Victrola, you
think about all the technology
that delivers music to consumers,
where all the money's made.
Right? It's not the, the
creators have always been screwed.
You know, it's always been
the hardware companies
that have made the money.
It's always been, you know.
Sony was an electronics company,
but because Betamax lost out to VHS,
they bought a movie studio.
We're not going to lose this next
time, we'll have our own content.
So, I think it was really
them strategically thinking,
we're going to now take equity
in all these new start-ups,
we don't know which ones are going
to succeed but if they do succeed,
we're going to be in for it.
>> Spree Wilson: Do you think it
was a like, from the Napster days,
of we didn't buy to the Napster
thing and we missed out on that?
>> John Simson: Well, you know,
the Napster thing is
kind of interesting.
As an aside, I was actually
subpoenaed in the Napster lawsuit,
but that's another
story for another day.
Shortest deposition in history.
But, I was actually
starting SoundExchange
out of the back of the RIAA.
When that was actually going on.
And the RIAA actually
reached out to Napster
and said, you guys need a license.
We should negotiate.
>> Jennifer cutting: Let's
spell out the acronyms,
Recording Industry
Association of America.
>> John Simson: Representing the
major labels and some major indies.
And this is back in 1999, 2000,
when Napster started
with the file sharing.
And they tried to license them.
And basically the answer was,
we don't need licenses,
this is fair use.
And finally, you know,
Napster got sued and they lost
in the 9th Circuit, and they
ended up getting shut down.
So, as, what's kind of
ironic, is that's 1999, 2000,
and now we have Spotify which is
basically a Napster with licenses.
>> Spree Wilson: Right.
>> John Simson: Right?
And it only took us 10 years to get
there and lots of losses to piracy
in the intervening years.
You know, I think there have
been band aids along the way,
the iTunes download store was
a wonderful thing for a while.
You know, people buying individual.
People wanted to buy the one
track, not the whole album,
okay, we'll let you do that.
And that was in response to Napster.
It was the record companies trying
to do something proactively.
You know, if you think about CD
stores, back when we had those,
like Tower and HMV, you know.
They weren't really interested
in selling CD singles.
Because you think about the profit
major on a CD single selling
for $2.99, taking up the
same amount of shelf space
in a record store as the full CD.
Right? So there was no business
in selling singles, you know.
When I was managing artists, we
might, you know, we had 45's right?
Then we had ca-singles.
You probably, don't.
I don't know if any of
you have any of those.
>> Spree Wilson: Maxi singles.
>> John Simson: And then,
yeah, the maxi singles.
If you're in the dance music.
You know, the 12 inch, you know.
>> Maria Schneider: Can
I just say something?
Because, and I know Taylor
Swift came out and said this.
You know, people are
willing to buy music.
First of all, I'll tell you through
my website, because I have all
of my data, I see every
sale that comes in.
The vast majority of
people are buying my CD.
Okay? And people are
willing to buy music.
People are willing to pay
for downloads and they work.
It's just if it's made available
for free, who doesn't use that?
You know, so this is not a
matter of what people want,
it's a matter of what large,
large companies have made us,
made people think that
they want and need.
Of course everybody takes
free if they get it.
At everybody's expense,
except their own.
And it's a dangerous thing for
us to not be awake to that.
And I really, so right now,
the copyright office is
doing a wonderful thing.
And they're taking in,
they've just closed it now,
in comments about Safe Harbor.
And a lot of people, I wrote
in, a lot of organizations,
I know Music Answers
wrote in, the RIAA.
>> John Simson: Thousands
of artists.
>> Maria Schneider: Thousands
of artists have written in.
Basically saying, you know,
and I think the argument needs
to be made definitely that you know,
these companies are
purposely setting this up.
And trying to create of culture of
infringement for their own good.
And
>> John Simson: If I
can just add to that.
When you were talking about the
Safe Harbor, this is the section 512
of the Digital Millennium
Copyright Act.
Where you send a notice, and the
person running the service has
to take it down, or they can be
held liable for infringement.
And again, remember it was
written during a time of dial up.
It was written during Netscape,
it was written during AOL.
We didn't have services
like Google and YouTube
which are content delivery systems.
This was really meant for dumb
pipes, that was the expression
that was used back in the day.
So here's the thing
that infuriated me.
You send a takedown notice for
a particular piece of content
that you own, and they take it down.
They abide by the law.
A minute later a new person
puts the same content up.
They don't have to filter and go,
oh wait, we already took that down.
Someone shouldn't be
able to put that back up.
They just put it back up.
It's like whack-a-mole.
And then you've got to send
them another takedown notice.
Now, if you're the major label
and you have a whole department
and that's all you do, sending tens
of millions, hundreds of millions,
of take down notices,
every month, you're okay.
But if you're an independent
artist, you can't afford to do that.
You don't have the
resources to do it.
There have been some
independent film makers,
who have made these independent
films on their credit cards,
only to see it being
distributed for free
because they can't
get it taken down.
And you know, the other
thing you were talking about,
how they try to threaten you when
you were taking something down.
You better have the
right to take this down,
or we're going to come after you.
>> Maria Schneider: And now
YouTube has just started a program
that if somebody takes, let's
not mind the fact that, you know,
probably 99.9% of takedown
notices are definitely authorized,
but every once in a while
somebody does a malicious takedown
on somebody, or whatever.
So, YouTube has started
saying that they will pay
up to a million dollars in
attorney's fees to defend some
of their users who
have something taken
down that they feel
is wrongly taken down.
Never mind are they're
going to pay, you know,
a million dollars of
my time and effort.
I want to, can I show you
something that just came out.
This is pretty wonderful
because, so,
the YouTube takedown
thing is frustrating.
The Google takedown
thing is impossible.
And Google, so it, I mean,
let's make no mistake,
Google and YouTube equal alphabet.
Which is you know, the big,
you know the data lord empire.
But Google is creating
searches to many of these sites.
Some that are foreign that don't
have to adhere to the DMCA.
Many are that torrent sites,
where you send in your DMCA thing
and they say, oh we can't
help it, it's server to server
and we can't do anything.
You know, in the meantime, they have
my entire sets of scores and parts
and videos that go with it that
are worth $115 on my website.
So, this man just put out this thing
about how to send a takedown notice
to Google in 46 or more easy steps.
So, let's get started.
Go to Google.com, look for the word
copyright at the bottom of the page?
Nope. Look for the word legal?
Nope. Look for the, contact
or contact us, nope, nope.
Link about, nope that's not it.
Link on terms, scroll down,
scroll down, how about privacy
and copyright protection,
now we're on our way.
Click on the link for help center.
Click on the link for submit
a legal request, okay.
Read the drop down menu, click
the link for the word tool,
read a set of 12 choices, select web
search, read a list of 8 choices,
none of the choices mention
the word copyright, really?
You invite me to submit
a legal request and none
of the choices are copyright,
and you receive 75 million
take down notices a month.
Okay, that's crazy.
So, select, I found a site that is
engaging in suspicious behavior.
The page is solely about phishing.
Go back, Google will
not let me go back.
Must start over.
Repeat step 11.
Select, I have a legal issue
that is not mentioned above.
I mean, this is incredible.
Ah ha, removing content from
Google is one of the choices.
Select. Warns me that they will
send my notice to the Lewin project,
formerly Chilling Effect,
and my notice will be
published for all to see.
Really? They haven't even found
out what I'm complaining about yet.
This is intimidation
tactic step number 1.
Are you the copyright
owner or authorized
to act on his or her behalf?
Select yes.
Select from two choices,
image video and other.
To speed things up and avoid yet
another menu that will inevitably go
with other, I select video image.
Google asks me to yes
or no the question,
the image video is of yourself?
Why this matters, I can't fathom.
I have already said I am the
copy owner, so I say yes.
DMCA form?
Nope, this warning appears.
Under U.S. copyright
law, a photograph
or video is generally owned by
the photographer videographer,
unless the photo was taken as part
of his or her responsibilities,
blah diddy blah diddy blah.
So this guy goes on to
say, but that's not true.
What if it's a selfie, then
I'm taking my own photo.
So then it goes on and on and on.
He hits every dead end.
So he goes, let's see I, let's see,
they demand that I provide them
a written assignment of copyright
or they will not process my request.
Intimidation tactic number 2.
Since I know better, I ignore this.
Click the link for here, request
for me to enter my email address.
Email address entered,
click returns.
Sorry Google doesn't
recognize that email.
Create an account using
that address.
You have to create a Google account.
Okay? Click next to an
attempt to bypass Google.
Will not let me fill
out a DMCA form,
unless I've created
a google account.
Creating a google account will
require me to divulge my name,
email address, birthdate, mobile
phone, it goes on and sign
up for all their, you
know, purple Kool Aid,
we get to the bottom, you know.
So, this is--
>> Spree Wilson: That's
the list online.
Imagine if you had no
list and you had to do
that all through experience.
Imagine how frustrated
you would be by step 12.
>> John Simson: I have a new
assignment for my students.
I'm going to give them that site.
>> Maria Schneider: But
this is, could any court
of law except maybe
one in Washington
when there's probably
three or four buildings
of Google lobbyists in this town.
Could any court of law, not
possibly look at that and say,
they really don't want
this stuff to come down.
I mean, come on.
You know, when there is
no list of such questions
when you put something up.
There's no, and even if you
submit a request and you say,
I don't want you to
link to that site,
or that's a Russian site that's,
you know, doing cyber or you know,
infringement or whatever.
This doesn't even guarantee
that link is going to come down.
So, one of the ideas that I had,
that I think would be amazing,
is that you know, with all these
data analytics, they should be able
to know, like, I 've done
many takedown requests.
And I've never had a counter
notification, you know.
Nobody's ever argued with it.
I should get a high rating.
I should be able to do fast
track to Google and say, hey,
Lime Torn, bad, bad company.
They're infringing my stuff so that
you know, thousands of other people,
like myself, millions
of other people,
like myself that have a high
rating, are given a warning
that Lime Torn is, that
they immediately take
down the URL to that company.
I mean, there are things they could
do, if somebody made them do it.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Maria,
what's the ray of hope?
There's so much broken.
We've had a wonderful list, a
litany of everything that's wrong,
and it really is not a
good situation for artists.
Is there a way for artists
to outsmart the data lords?
Is there way to circumvent,
is there a way
to outsmart, is there a way to?
>> Maria Schneider: There are
two things that are going on.
So one, is at the very beginning
I think she said something
about musicanswers.org, and I
want to tell you about that.
Because a group of musicians
started this in New York
and I'm a part of it,
and so is Spree.
And the idea is that
a lot of organizations
that were representing you know,
write and advocacy and
doing great things.
But none of those were
really for performers,
songwriters, composers
and producers.
The people that actually
make the music
without also having
the record companies
and the publishers in there.
Even ASCAP and BMI, you know,
they've got the publishers,
they've got the writers, and
there's always this little bit
of conflict and competition.
So this, we all have the same,
basically the same interest.
So, we decided to create
this campaign,
and create a declaration
of principles.
And the declaration of
principles is basically to,
that people can sign on, and
say, these are the basic things
that we all must agree
and adhere to.
Transparency.
Here's some we come together
as writers, performers.
We oppose practices of
video streaming services,
internet services and
other businesses
that appropriate the value
of our music in order
to make huge profits
selling advertising and data.
We believe like music
should be treated like.
That means performance and composer.
That this really should
be, fair is fair.
Transparency and, so people
are signing on to this.
We already have Carole
King, Herbie Hancock,
we have Steve Wright,
we have John Corviano.
>> Spree Wilson: David Byrne.
>> Maria Schneider: David
Byrne, we have many, many people
and we're trying to get students.
And we're creating all sorts
of videos to wake people up,
so the ideas is education.
And anybody can sign up.
People can sign up as fans, as
people in the music industry
to basically get people to say,
yeah, this is what we believe,
and this is what we
want to advocate for.
And have this huge list of
names, and we're already
up to 1600 and we just got started.
And have this huge list of
names and videos and things
that say, we're watching you.
We want better, we expect better.
We now know what's going
on, we're not going
to sleep at the wheel anymore.
So, if you can't change Congress
and you can't change it through law,
you can change it through
exposure and pressure.
And then the other thing
that I always advocate for,
because it works so much for me,
and that is Artist Share gave me
this opportunity to put my music
out there, this platform
where I can connect
with fans in meaningful ways.
And Taylor Swift is a big
advocate of connecting with fans,
and I can tell you from
me, it works beautifully.
And you know, sharing, my
whole process and everything
and having access to all that data
and knowing every person
who buys my music.
Owning my music.
Not giving away my rights.
Running my own show.
Having my own archive
of my own work.
And you know, I'm able to
pay for a $200,000 record.
In an industry where almost nobody
can pay for a $200,000 record.
And it's jazz big band.
So, I was always imagine, I
look at, you know, some artists,
I look at Taylor Swift you
know, and I imagine her numbers
if she was doing what I was doing.
Insanely eye popping.
I mean, really.
>> John Simson: Well I mean but you
saw, when she withheld her music
from Spotify, from
the free services.
And look what happened with Adele.
She said no to Spotify,
8 million sales.
So you still can sell.
>> Maria Schneider: People buy.
>> John Simson: People will buy
if they can't get it for free.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
That's the point.
People will buy if they
can't get it for free.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
So, just say no.
That's one of the take
aways from this.
So as the takeway--
>> Maria Schneider:
Wait, just one second--
>> Spree Wilson: I just want to add
something, just like, I think also,
one key component is you have
to switch the way of thinking.
Just, just to people
in general, you know.
Especially people of my age
and generation, it's like,
you have to understand there's a
group of kids from 2000 to 2016
who have grown up and have never
paid for music in their life.
They have no concept of going to a
store, buying a cd, taking it home,
putting on some headphones,
unwrapping the cd,
turn the music on, looking at the
credits and vibing out to music.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
reading the liner notes.
>> Spree Wilson: Exactly.
Their whole idea of what music is,
is almost like background noise.
Like, have you heard that new Drake
song, that new Taylor Swift song?
We'll play it in the background
as we get ready for a party.
And I just think you have to change
the idea of what music is to people
to make them feel like
it's something special,
and not just this thing that
they're supposed to have.
That they're, and it just
comes for free, you know.
That's a longer road
to get to I feel like,
but it can be done, you know.
>> Maria Schneider: If there was a,
I'll tell you if there was a
financial motivation for that
from a company like Google, they
would make it happen overnight.
Because they've manage to change a
generation, and once that, you know,
once that dam is broken,
that's their idea.
All the dams are broken, this
is how people get music now.
It's like wow.
This is what the damage
they've done.
>> Spree Wilson: And so
it's just an awareness also,
I think making the issue
with music being free up,
not just a music issue but a
people issue, a person issue.
You know, like, when
you think about people
who aren't getting paid
the right amount of wages,
you all feel for them, you know.
Like, I did when I said
I got $60 for a song
that was streamed millions of times,
I heard the whole crowd
just gasp, you know.
Because how could that
happen, you know?
Just imagine, like, I think
when people think of songs
and songwriters and artists,
they think about these guys
who have millions and millions of
dollars and it's really one percent
of the entire pie, who
is that successful.
>> John Simson: Less
than one percent.
>> Spree Wilson: Yeah, for the most
part, I'm from Nashville, Tennessee,
for the most part, people are,
people have worked
their whole lives just
to live a decent life writing songs.
That's all they've
ever known, you know.
And as the years progress,
that likelihood of providing
for their family gets taken
away from them every day.
>> Maria Schneider: Well, and we
know from the copyright report,
I think we've talked about it
today, how many songwriters
in Nashville have left
the profession
in the last, I don't know,
>> John Simson: Like
10 years, 12 years.
>> Maria Schneider: 80%.
>> Spree Wilson: This
is a songwriters city.
This was a city that
was built on songwriting
and to see these people not be
able to take care of their family,
provide for their household.
It's sad, it's really sad.
Because this is not
just a music thing,
it's a person, it's a people thing.
You know, just imagine, like
you're going, you guys are going
to your jobs tomorrow, and just
imagine your boss comes in and says,
hey, today you guys are
going to be working for free.
I'm sorry.
That's just the, or you know
what, we're going to pay you,
but we're not going to tell you
how much we're going to pay you.
>> John Simson: How
about a penny an hour.
>> Spree Wilson: I think your job
is worth zero zero zero point 4,
give or take just, you know.
So.
>> Maria Schneider: Or it's like
going to Congress and saying hey,
we just found a way to
hack into all your 401K's
and give away $15 little things.
Everybody, here, have
a frenzy at it.
And everybody can just pick
away and say oh cool, wow,
I can get $15 from
[inaudible], cool.
I'm going to take $15 from you know,
and they just go around,
and that's what it is.
It's like, I used to work sometimes
with Toots, Toots Goman and he used
to say when he would
announce playing the Blusette,
before he would play it,
this is my social security.
This song, you know.
It is, your songs are your assets.
They're something that should
pay you and, you know, your kids,
and you know, for 75
years, you know.
It should belong to you
and it should be protected.
And you know what, it's
in our constitution.
Copyright is in our constitution.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
And this is the home
of U. S. copyright, the
Library of Congress.
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Thank you all so much
for your eloquence on this subject.
And I'm just very curious
how many creators are
in the audience tonight?
Okay, for those who are music
creators, as a take away,
I'm just going to ask
what is one thing,
I'm going to ask all three of you.
What is one thing that music
creators can take away,
to take home tonight from
this panel that they can do it
when they get home, to
better protect their rights
in the digital marketplace.
John?
>> John Simson: Sure.
Well, for one thing there are
lots of different pools of money.
And if you've put out recordings,
and your recordings have been played
on Sirius XM, if they've been played
on Pandora, if they've been played
on any of these streaming
services, you want to make sure
that you are signed up to
collect from all those pools.
And so most people know that if
they're a songwriter they have
to sign up with ASCAP, BMI or SESAC,
those are pretty much
your three choices.
You can self-publish, you don't have
to go through one of the PRO's, but,
you know, most people go
through one of those three.
Make sure you're a member.
They collect money from the
public performance of your work
as a composer for the composition.
SoundExchange, the organization
I started 16 years ago now,
collects for you as a recording
artist and for you as a label owner.
Make sure, if you own your own
masters, if you are the label
as well as the artist, you
sign up for both shares.
Frequently an artist signs up with
SoundExchange and they only sign
up as the artist, not
thinking oh, I own the masters,
I'm the label owner too, and they
leave half the money on the table.
And we used to have
to track people down,
when all of a sudden there'd be
this pool of money and we'd go,
wait a minute, you know,
we don't know this label,
we'd call the artist and go,
do you know who the label is?
Oh, I'm the label.
So, very simply you make sure you
sign up as the artist, as the label.
If you're a background musician and
you play on other people's records,
especially if you play on
major records, there is a fund
that is controlled by the AFM and
AFTRA that's American Federation
of Musicians and now it's
SAG-AFTRA, but American Federation
of Television and Radio Artists, has
an intellectual property fund based
in California and they get 5%
of the all the money
SoundExchange collects,
so about $40 million last year,
be probably $50 million
dollars this year.
And there's also other reuse fees
when songs get put in movies,
when they get reused for other
things, so there's probably well
over $100 million dollars a
year for background musicians
and background vocalists if you
play on fairly popular recordings.
You have to get in touch with them
and let them know who you are,
and where they can find you.
So, it's really important
to let people know.
There's another much smaller fund.
It's probably $2 to 3
million dollars a year,
it's located here in Washington.
It's called AARC, the Alliance of
Artists and Recording Companies.
I used to be on their board and
basically they collect money back
when dat tape was going
to revolutionize the world
and we got this law
passed, that, you know,
that every time blank media would be
used to copy things or hard drives,
but we got screwed on that.
Because unlike Europe where
lots of money is being collected
in these levies, we don't
get hard drives on computers
because they're multi use.
We don't get blank cd levies
unless it says a music cd,
and most people just
buy regular blank cds.
But it could be hundreds
of millions of dollars
if people were actually
paying for the media
on which they're copying our stuff.
So AARC, again, is something
that you should look up.
I believe, if you google
Alliance of Artists
and Recording Companies,
you'll find it.
>> Jennifer Cutting: And
SoundExchange's web site is?
>> John Simson: Soundexchange.com
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Soundexchange.com
>> John Simson: And they actually
have a place on the website
where you can actually search
to see if you have money.
And I just saw a wonderful
site, called buzz angle,
of course it's way more expensive
than you'd ever want to spend,
but I found out I had 35
streams on Spotify on my record
that has never been
digitally released.
So I still king of mystified,
until I found out that somebody
has been bootlegging it.
So I'm owed 16 cents.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Spree?
Thanks John.
>> Spree Wilson: I just think
the biggest way, the most,
or one of the ways you can
protect yourself is just
through awareness, you know.
When I was a kid, nobody
had any information for me.
There wasn't a lawyer to go to,
or there wasn't another artist,
I literally had to either,
it was trial by fire
or figure it out as I go.
So I think for artists and
just people who are interested
in the subject matter at
hand, it's just research.
Awareness, when the
article comes out, read it.
I know it's a lot of information
to take in, and you're not going
to figure this whole thing out
in a day, maybe not even a year.
But the more you keep abreast of it
and the more awareness that you have
of it, of how your music is getting
out there, what you're getting paid
for your music, what are different
avenues to put your music through,
I think, I think will give
you much more protection
because you won't go
into it so blindly.
You know, there's millions of kids
are tossing their music on Spotify
and have no idea how much they're
getting paid or if they're supposed
to be getting paid at all.
So, I think that the more
you know, as they used to say
on the NBC thing, the more you
know, the more you going to prepare,
of you know, how to
attack the giant, the data.
>> Maria Schneider: The data lords
>> Spree Wilson: The data
lords of the music industry.
>> Maria Schneider: So, absolutely.
I mean, that's what we're
trying to do at Music Answers.
So, I hope that you will
go to Music Answers,
look at the videos we're
making and you can endorse the,
if you like the declaration
of principles,
to me there's nothing not to love.
You endorse it, sign up, and then,
you know, we'll keep you apprised
of what's going on and
what things are changing.
There are a lot of
sites you can go to,
Music Business Worldwide is a
wonderful, just sign up there.
Everyday articles come
in, and just shockers,
you know, about the business.
It's really good.
ASCAP has a wonderful sort
of advocacy, you know,
they upload all sorts of
links and things of things
that are coming out every day.
And they're all tools that
just help people to know
and I do think the more people that
know and the more people that share,
and say, you know this
isn't what I think.
And are vocal about it.
And, it puts pressure on
these companies to change.
I mean, you have to
demand transparency.
And fairness and you know.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Thank you.
Thank you.
You've all been so articulate
about all of these issues.
Let's have a round of
applause for everybody.
[ Applause ]
And now, we'd like to hear from you.
What are your questions?
Do you have any questions for
our highly qualified panelists?
Please take a mic.
>> Hello. My name is Howard Crowell,
I'm actually a Grammy member.
Which is how I found out about this.
I have a question, you said that
the Congress is not doing enough.
I know that, you know, I go to,
we have something called
Grammies on the Hill every year.
I've been going there
for the last four years.
So every year, a lot of
politicians, you know, Nancy Pelosi,
they all come to this huge major
event that is supposed to bring,
you know, music performers
and lawmakers together.
and they all promise that they're
going to kind of deal with this,
this you know, this problem
with our copyright infringement
and things like that.
And it doesn't seem like
we're making any progress.
It seems like every year, you know,
we as the members we
get these emails
from the hill saying you know, we're
going to tackle this this year,
go to your neighbor, talk
to your member of Congress.
You know, kind of rally the
troops and it doesn't seem
like we're making progress.
So, why do you think that is?
>> Maria Schneider: It's
because of lobbying.
You know, because, it's marvelous
that you came here for
Grammys on the Hill.
That's a great, great event.
And it is a wonderful experience
to experience all these musicians
getting together and getting
to have meetings with Congressmen
and tell them our issues.
So I applaud you for doing that.
It's, it's a huge thing and I
think it can make a difference.
And it does make a difference.
But I also know that in
our meetings, you know,
I remember Jerry Nadler,
sitting over his desk and saying,
The radio lobby is really strong.
You know. Just that giving a
little bit of a reality check
that these forces and
lobbying is you know,
is powerful, powerful stuff.
And, and that's why I do think it's
so important that organizations
like NARIS that are doing
things, and what we're doing,
and all these different
organizations,
grass roots people, the individuals.
I know Jerry Nadler told me,
it's the individual stories,
the people coming like Spree and
saying, I had 45 million views
and they sent me a check for $30.
He said that those kind of
stories mean a lot to them, and so,
you know, I guess we just have
to, we just have to keep pushing
and trying and hoping and
doing everything we can.
>> John Simson: You know, I think
having been a lobbyist myself
for a number of years when
I was running SoundExchange,
interestingly back in 1994 my
partner who is here tonight,
Tom Karic and I were approached by
the Recording Industry Association
of America to join
a lobbying campaign.
To get a law passed to make
broadcasters pay recording artists
when they played songs on the radio.
And we got our clients involved,
and we reached out to other artists
that we knew and other managers,
and got people involved.
And we had this campaign going
to get a full performance
rite in the United States.
And when we failed to get that
done, we did not get radio stations
to pay, but when we went to the
digital side during that campaign
in 1995, who was our ally?
The broadcasters.
Because they sat there and said, Oh,
our future competitors who are going
to be doing satellite radio
and internet radio,
all this digital stuff.
They're going to have to pay a
royalty that we don't have to pay.
So, because the broadcasters
are on our side
and these digital services didn't
exist yet, we got the law passed.
In 1995, the Digital Performance
Right and Sound Recordings Act.
The first time recording artists
in the United States ever
were entitled to get paid.
And now it's 20 years old.
The broadcasters of course kind
of shot themselves in the foot.
They didn't realize.
They thought they had exempted
themselves from ever having to pay.
But now when they stream
online, they do have to pay.
You know, so they're a little
bit upset because they realize
that eventually they'll be
streaming online completely.
But you know, they make $17
billion a year playing ads
around music, and we get zero.
Songwriters get a little.
But not nearly enough.
I mean, imagine if you
had, if you owned music.
At a rate, a guy said I have
this brand-new invention.
It's called radio and
here's what I'm going to do.
I'm going to play your songs,
amass people listening.
I'm going to sell ads.
But I'm not going to
give you anything
because you'll sell concert tickets.
You'll sell records.
It's fine.
I'm going to make $17
billion but I'm not going
to guarantee you anything.
That's not a very good deal.
You can't even say no.
It'd be one thing if
you could say no,
I don't want you to use my stuff.
But you don't even have the right
under US Copyright Law to say no.
As Maria said, there's a broadcaster
in every congressional district.
If you want to get elected, you
need to be on the radio and TV.
So, that's why the broadcasters
are such a strong lobbying force.
You know, Congress always said
to us when we would come to them,
when we almost had a deal in 2010
where the broadcasters finally
agreed to pay something.
When the broadcasters and you
guys come together with a deal
that everybody's willing to
agree to, we'll bless it.
You'll have legislation.
That's the only way
it'll ever happen.
And I think given the power
of Google and these companies,
that's the only way that will ever
happen is if the tech companies,
you know, and the music
industry come together with a,
some sort of a bill that they can.
>> Maria Schneider: Just in case
some people don't understand this,
performance royalty
is for the performer.
So, for instance, Aretha Franklin
has been on the radio how many,
you know, millions
and millions of times.
She never got a penny.
>> John Simson: No
respect [laughter].
>> Maria Schneider: She never-
>> John Simson: Otis got
respect because he wrote it.
>> Maria Schneider: But
she never got a penny.
What are the 2 countries,
there's only 2, like-
>> John Simson: No,
there's more than a couple.
But they're not-
>> Maria Schneider: Notable ones.
>> John Simson: Yeah, North Korea
doesn't pay, Iraq doesn't pay,
Sudan doesn't pay, Iran doesn't pay.
Pretty much all the other countries
in the world pay performers
when they play it on the radio.
>> Maria Schneider: Those
countries, the sad part is
because it's not reciprocal,
because, so in Germany, GEMA,
they have a great performing rights
organization, GEMA in Germany.
Because we don't pay their artists
when their German artists are
on the radio here because we don't
pay them a performance royalty,
therefore they don't
pay Aretha Franklin's.
And so these countries, I
know a guy, he said they,
he had a hit down in Brazil
with Brazilian musicians
and he was one of the songwriters.
Or performers on it.
And, or was a hit worldwide
or something.
His friends, you know,
they all made great money.
They had like apartments
on Copacabana, you know?
And this guy didn't get a penny.
So it's hurting us internationally.
>> John Simson: He needs to call me.
I can get him the money.
>> Spree Wilson: Yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: I
mean, the international,
it would be interesting to get
the international loss of income
into the United States from that.
>> John Simson: I did
a little bit of that
when we were leading this campaign
and it's hard to totally quantify
but US repertoire except
in certain countries
where language issues are
pretty major, it's 30 to 50%
of the world's repertoire.
So, when you look at that, the
labels get their share, by the way.
Because remember, when
your record comes
out in the UK, it comes
out on Sony UK.
They're a local company,
they get paid.
The artist, if they're
American, is an American artist.
They don't get paid.
So, we estimated somewhere around
$100 million to $150 million a year
that US artists were
losing in foreign royalties.
So, it's not insignificant.
When you think about it,
and also the other piece
that people forget is, you
know, it's not all pop music.
Europe plays a lot
more classical music.
They play a lot more jazz.
And so it's a lot of really niche
music that is losing that money.
EDM for years, it's starting
to obviously catch up here
but for years there
were artist here.
There were loopholes.
So for example, one of the things
I would tell people is go record
in London and if you record
in London, then you can get
to collect your royalties
around the world.
>> Spree Wilson: That's exactly
what my business manager,
he gave me this bit of
advice which enabled me
to get a lot more money overseas
which with the Afrojack song, Spark,
because it was a Dutch artist,
I was able, and I was a writer
and a performer on the song.
I was able to collect all the money
that probably would've
been withheld from me.
>> Maria Schneider: That's
why because you told me
that I was asking him about
his BMI royalties and he said
that the foreign royalties are
pretty good and that's why.
Because I was little surprised.
>> John Simson: Well, wouldn't BMI,
it would be your foreign royalties-
>> Maria Schneider: But they're
coming through BMI or, well-
>> John Simson: They're probably
coming through either SoundExchange
or you might have a
business manager.
>> Spree Wilson: Yeah, a
business manager, yeah.
>> Maria Schneider: Okay.
>> John Simson: I actually did
that for Cobalt for awhile as a-
>> Jennifer Cutting: I want to
get to a few more questions.
>> Maria Schneider: Okay, sorry.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Does
that answer your question?
>> Yes, yes.
Thank you.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Very fully.
Other questions?
>> Nelson, from Altavoz
Entertainment.
I actually want to follow up with
Jerry and what people can do.
There is something called the
music act, go to musicact.org.
And that is supported by Jerry,
introduced, and it's supposed
to give US record labels up to $1
million a year to make, manufacture
and export US-made music.
Why we don't, and I've been going
to Grammys on the Hill for 15 years.
We don't, because we have
Halliburton-ized the US
recording industry.
US-made music is not
exported out of the US.
You're not going to
make money digitally.
Digitally is only a fraction
of all the money earned.
You have to do both.
And we have a music act.
We need to get people to go.
You need to get your
local representative
to go why are we not doing
anything supporting our local music?
Because Sony, Universal
and Warner Bros.
Warner Bros., actually BMG is back.
There are four majors.
BMG has Janet Jackson, Alabama,
Scarface, it's not in the news.
But they're back because
majors make billions
of dollars selling records still.
And they're getting
everybody else to go play
in the digital sandbox
that makes microcents.
So, you have to do both.
The other thing is
you need block chain.
It has to be tied to
a public block chain
and then your rights
will all get done out.
And we're fighting
this out in industry.
>> Maria Schneider:
What is a block chain?
>> So, the block chain is
what this crypto currency is.
This is a public ledger that
would allow all the right holders
to have their information
promulgated out and then
if someone used it,
it's tied to a pair key
so your information goes
out, you have a public key
that allows it to the broadcast.
You have a private key
that your information,
say I want to use it,
I get it right.
It reports back to you.
It would send a payment
to him the songwriter.
It would send it to
your distributor,
to your aggregators, all done.
>> Maria Schneider: One place.
>> But guess who doesn't like that?
The established people
in our industry.
And so the indies have
to take it back.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Thank you.
Other questions?
>> Yeah. Actually I have got
about 10 questions but
I'll start with one.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Pick your favorite one.
>> I've watched stuff on YouTube
and I could never figure out, like,
first of all, I hate YouTube.
I can't understand why you would
actually get music from YouTube.
Is it just a place?
I mean, like, when
people go to YouTube,
do they just, using it like a radio?
Like to play it?
>> Maria Schneider: Check
stuff out, just to get,
to check it out without buying it.
>> John Simson: It's on demand, too.
Because they let everything
stay up there.
They don't take anything down,
so you know you'll
find everything there.
>> Because my question
was I'm a photographer.
And photography is being
destroyed on the Internet.
It's just, it's unbelievable.
Because if you are represented by
an agency, you know, AP or Magnum,
they really can't do anything.
They do stuff for marquee
photographers.
The biggest concern isn't so
much that photography is showing
up in all these websites and
nobody can do anything about it.
What seems to be particularly
irritating to a lot
of photographers is that
their work is being taken
and the individuals are then
doing stuff to it and reposting it
in some other form that's not
what its original intent was.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Analogous to sampling.
>> And it's just like,
when you see it, I mean,
I've heard from photographers
who said I saw
and I didn't even know
it was mine at first
and I remember, what is this?
And that is just, it's maddening.
And only really in
the top, only the top,
I know most people don't
know a lot about photography
but like you get some premier
photographs, Magnum or AP
or Reuters will come down and
they'll, the lawyers will show up.
But for the most part,
it's Katie bar the door.
>> John Simson: I was going to
say, I actually was involved
in some meetings last year about,
with some of the photographing
agencies about trying
to create a SoundExchange-like
right for photographers
so that basically people
could use them online
but there would be charges,
you know, on websites.
And they'd have to pay percentages
of revenue, things like that.
And then the pool would come in
and then you'd have to figure
out how to, it's very difficult.
Obviously, more difficult
than songs.
>> Yeah, it's, I mean, they do,
each agency has their own mechanism
but each one of them is different,
different forms, different price.
But they really say we don't
want you taking the photographs
and changing them around.
And I guess I'm not 100% sure,
because I see a lot of stuff
on YouTube, and it seems
to me like nonsense.
Like, if I have a daughter and
she looks up a Beyonc song,
she'll get 30 things that aren't
even the things she's looking for.
And some of them are actually,
sometimes they're even pornographic,
which I don't know what,
how that's allowed.
>> Spree Wilson: It's funny you
say that because we talked about,
we had this conversation about remix
culture and like a photographer,
like your photographs when somebody
takes sitting re-purposes it.
They do the same thing with music.
Like I've had songs where somebody
just found it, found a cappella
and did a remix and had it
on every, it's a repurposed.
It's my song but they repurpose
the for their own, like,
artistic creative choice, whatever.
And they're, I don't know
if they're making money
from it but it's the same thing.
It's so hard to have
somebody take it down.
You know? Because a remix, it
could be 1000 remixes one song
and sometimes you just don't even
know how many remixes there are,
you know?
I've had a song that
was remixed 20 times.
I've only heard it like 10.
It's just that somebody sent me
a paperwork of all the remixes
that someone to the research
but I haven't heard all the
remixes so I just don't know.
Like, and it's the same
with your photographs.
Like, you just don't know how many
times somebody has reposted your
photograph, especially
in the social media age.
Man, we're like I could take your
picture and put a filter on it
and then I could distribute
it to thousands of people
and somebody else take that same
picture and do the same thing.
You just have no idea.
You know? There's no, like,
like I wish there was some kind
of like watermark or they take
watermarks off now too so it's
like I just don't know how
you can keep up with any
of the artwork or your work.
You know?
>> John Simson: It's like
first-grade Photoshop.
Eliminate all that stuff.
>> Jennifer Cutting:
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We have time for one more question?
>> Hi. Hello?
So I wanted to sort of get some
feedback from you about one
of the aspects that I think is under
discussed in terms of the transition
from the ownership model to the
access model and that's how the,
it gets talked about in terms
of total industry revenues.
And I want to talk about how those
revenues end up being distributed
across different kinds of art.
You know, different kinds
of music is intended
for different kinds of listening.
There's pop music, which I love,
which is sort of the kind of stuff
that you listen to over
and over again and kind
of can be the soundtrack
to your life.
And then there's kind of
music that's not for everyone.
Like big-band jazz or the noisy
punk rock that I make my basement.
It's never going to be mass
audience music in the same way.
And it might be not the kind
of thing you return to over
and over again for repeat
listening over and over again
but a few listeners that you do
sit down and really take it in
and can be transformative and really
powerful artistic experiences.
And one of the challenges with the
on-demand streaming economics is
that it seems set up to
reward the kind of pop music.
Repeat listening over and over and
over again for a period of years
at the expense of sort of the
art music, the fewer listens,
the niche, the little guys.
I'm really concerned about
whether there's any kind
of economic incentive
to validate those.
I mean, I'm excited
by what you're saying
about building those direct
relationships with fans
and explaining the economics
to them being a means
of recourse to counterbalance that.
I'm wondering if you're
getting those kinds of feedback
from your communities as well?
>> Maria Schneider: Well, one
thing, so I was talking to a person
in the music business in
New York just about Spotify
in the way they calculate, you know,
when there's a $9.99
subscription fee.
And I hadn't heard about this before
and I thought it's
an incredible idea.
He said he feels that if somebody
pays, if you pay $9.99 per month
and you're listening is,
you know, big band jazz
and that's all you listen
to and maybe listen 9 times.
That, he said your 9.99 should go,
be divvied up to the
people that you listen to.
And if you're a person
that pays 9.99 a month
and you listen 5000 times,
you know, to something else,
then it gets divvied up by 5000
times amongst those things.
And I think that there is a certain
beauty in that because I think
that people would be maybe more
likely to pay a subscription fee
if they knew that the
money actually was going
to those people that they listen to.
I think that would be a meaningful
change and a meaningful step.
Now, there are a lot of people
that are not going to like that.
You know? But I think it would
be good and good for the music.
And then obviously, you
know, I'm just a fan
of what I described
before for myself.
But that little step
in the streaming world I think
would make the difference.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Thank you.
>> John Simson: Yeah, I
think if you think about it,
we have the technology
to be able to do that.
I mean, that's the most fair
way to distribute the money,
based on total plays
per user for the fee-
>> Maria Schneider: Yeah.
Going to those people.
I mean, it's easy to do that.
So, yeah, but it's difficult.
And this is changing.
It is going to change
your musical culture.
You know, because it is hurting
those little niche musics
that don't have, you know,
as big of an audience.
And usually that music is the
most expensive to record, too.
That's the irony.
You know, the classical music
and it's, so it's tough.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Thank you.
Thanks for your question.
>> Maria Schneider: One more.
>> I just want to ask one question.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Okay, one more.
Let's get you on mic.
>> Okay, so it's really quick.
This kind of pertains to
me and like if I don't know
if I'm going the right
direction or not.
But I should think you maybe if
you can let me know if I'm not.
But, okay, so basically
I'm an aspiring musician.
My music name is Rosebud.
It's enchanting, it's
captivating music, bliss.
A lot of people say it
gets underneath her skin
in a peaceful manner.
So, I want to know,
of course is a creator
of your music, it's like a baby.
You know, like you created.
So I did copyrighted, I copyrighted
it, like maybe about 3 weeks ago.
But am hesitant, I don't know
if it's me, like, being scared
or it's like, I just
want to protect it.
But you know how like
I can go to someone
and he may have a recording
studio and they want to record it.
Like, am I going the right way
or should I have like documents
to show, like, you know, the way to
protect it or this is what's going
on and make it pacific in writing?
>> Spree Wilson: Are you asking
if somebody's recording
your song for you?
>> Yeah, like, I mean, should
I be putting it on YouTube,
should I be putting
it on like SoundCloud?
I don't know.
I'm a very critical thinker.
Times, certain stuff like this.
So, I'm not so, like, quick to jump.
So, I just want to know-
>> Spree Wilson: Well,
the first question is,
what are you looking for?
Like, that would be my
first question as an artist.
Like, what are you, what
is your goal with the song.
Because sometimes it's
not about making money.
Sometimes it's just
about being heard, right?
So if SoundCloud is the way
for you to get heard, you know,
that might be a outlet or it
might be like what Maria said.
Like, she has a platform where
you can put your song out.
Or it might just be a
personal agreement with you
and whoever you're
recording a song with.
But I think the first thing you
should ask yourself is like,
what is my goal but this song?
What is my goal this music?
And I think that can guide you into
whatever direction you're going in.
Everything else is just
about research, you know?
Spotify, how much they'll pay
you, SoundCloud or whatever.
But you should ask yourself, like,
how do I want to get
this music heard?
Like, what's the best
platform for it?
And I think everything else
will guide you after that.
>> Maria Schneider: And I also
think that thinking ahead,
because you're just starting out.
If I was just starting
out right now,
my goal would be building
my own career.
And if you throw your stuff, I
think you want to pick those things
that you want to get
out there as a magnet
but then you want the
things that you preserve.
There's a new thing
that's just starting now,
it's called fanfunded.com.
It's basically like artists
share light, that anybody can do.
But the beauty of it
is that you will know,
you will build your own audience.
You will know who they are.
You can contact them.
You can share things with them,
and you can build a career.
So, the idea isn't just making that
first record or doing those songs
and necessarily on the first
one making all your money back.
But then maybe your next
one builds so people get
to know what you're doing
and you know who they are.
You, then when you do
your second record,
you already have this many
people you can send out an email
and say hey, or note or
however they're going
to communicate, you know.
I am now going to fund
another record or I'm going
to create a single or
I'm going on a trip here
and I'm writing music about this.
Come follow along.
You can help fund it or whatever.
And building it.
So that you have your own
little empire at the end.
Because otherwise they
will suck you dry.
You know? It's very
difficult these days.
I think it's very important.
Ownership is everything.
>> John Simson: And I think Maria
makes a really good point which is
if you, one of the
problems with some
of these big streaming services
is that they don't tell you
that people are more
listening to you.
And that's most valuable data,
is having that relationship
with that fan, having
their email address,
knowing who they are,
knowing what they like.
You know, and because that way
you have a direct relationship.
You can monetize it or you
can give it away for free
but you have a community.
I think that's important.
>> Spree Wilson: Sometimes it's
about putting those breadcrumbs out.
Like she says, she has
wonderful platform which is
like put the breadcrumbs out
there and then direct them
to your own platform where
you can be the beneficiary of.
>> Maria Schneider: Build
it and they will come.
Slow and steady is, you
know, slow and steady
and being good to your fans.
That is, you know, creating
a relationship of trust
and respect is a huge part of it.
>> Jennifer Cutting: Thank you.
I want to say a big
thanks to all my panelists.
Maria Schneider, Spree Wilson, John
Simson, for being with us tonight.
Thanks also to the music division
folks who planned this panel
and all the events in Maria's
weeklong jazz residency.
Ann McLean, Nick Brown,
David Plyler.
We'd also like to thank our
sound engineers Mike Turpin
and Jay Kemlaw.
Thank you very much.
And videographer Thom
Wolf, thank you.
Before we go, I just want to let you
know about one more upcoming event.
The concert is sold out so
we can't invite you to that
but Maria has an upcoming
workshop this Saturday, April 16.
That's at 2 o'clock.
It runs from 2 o'clock
to 4 o'clock and it's
in our beautiful Coolidge Auditorium
in the Jefferson building,
the one in the big down.
Maria will be working with members
of the Bohemian Caverns
Jazz Orchestra
and the Levine Music
Premier Jazz Combo.
And both of the groups will perform
and then Maria will give them
some coaching and some feedback
in a workshop-style environment.
But the workshop is free of charge.
So, seating is first-come,
first-served
but there's loads of
room in the Coolidge.
It's a big auditorium.
So, we're hoping to see you
there this Saturday at 2 PM
in the Coolidge and I
want to thank you all
so much for coming out tonight.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]